as rumors persist that jody whittaker
may be ending her time as the doctor
following the end of series 13 the
question is
who should take over but we're in the
unique
position of possibly having already met
them
[Music]
[Music]
hey there folks i wanted to get this out
into the world before anything becomes
official about jody whitaker leaving
or uh her replacement being announced
because if i wait too long this will all
be moot so
i want to talk about the possibility
and arguments that i've heard both for
and against
the idea of joe martin taking up the
mantle
of the doctor now we have already
actually
seen joe martin b the doctor
she got introduced in fugitive of the
jedoon
now we haven't seen a ton of her since
then and also depending on what actually
happens in series 13
whether or not she shows up there and we
get more of an explanation
of who she is and how she fits into the
doctor's timeline
well it may not be a viable option
narratively depending on what else we
find out about her
so i accept that going in and if that is
the case then
maybe the conversation again might be
moot but i still want to have it anyways
because
i think there's some things to be taken
into consideration or at least talked
about
for the fairly unique position that
we're in right now
so joe martin as the doctor
after jody whitaker well
there's a number of things i've seen
floated both for and against that idea
on the one hand while not everybody
loved it i know i for one
thought she had she handled herself
wonderfully
when she showed up on screen she
commanded the screen she had
so much presence i even saw a lot of
people who weren't that
fond of jody really take to her and be
like
this is kind of what i wish we had more
of right now
so i feel like there is a pretty strong
show of support from the fandom i mean
some people didn't like it some people
don't like absolutely anything going on
with doctor who right now and
sometimes they have reasons and are
willing to explain them
at great length for anywhere up to five
hours and you know what i honestly
appreciate putting in that kind of
effort
others just wag a fig finger and go chip
gymnal jody bad
and i really have no time for that but
regardless there was a pretty positive
response to her first reveal
and introduction so that feels like a
good starting point
it would absolutely feel like a massive
waste of potential
if we didn't get more of her in some
fashion
and at least right now as things stand
the way that makes the most sense for
her to take over is to become the next
doctor
now again narratively we don't know
whether or not that fits she may be
established as a preheartenal doctor
or she could still feasibly show up as
being
part of this uh series 6b
theory um that had been used to cover
some of the
weird flubs going on in the two doctors
back
when that thing happened or you know it
could
be a case that we actually find out she
was a later incarnation of the doctor
but for whatever reason
did not know jody didn't recall her and
that might end up being what gets
explained so
all these things are still open
possibilities
the main thing that i've seen sort of
brought to the table
as an argument against having her take
over
is kind of well losing a big part of the
fun
of the speculation of the
excitement wondering what a new actor
even after their cast will look like in
the part
how they will perform it there's
going to be like a kind of a sense of
anti-climax
if we don't get to have that big reveal
announcement whether it be
on a stage or done as a as a released
video like they did with jody whitaker
or however they choose to do it
that will kind of just be
a little bit limp if it turns out oh
it's the
it's the person we already met and i
understand
some reservations or a sense of loss
at not having that but
if i can be completely honest that
strikes me as a fairly
superficial reason to not
consider her i mean
this is not me saying that the people
who feel this way are superficial
and don't care about deeper things but
i'm just saying that that's the kind of
thing that is only in the moment anyways
and i'm not saying there's no value in
that but i'm saying
as time goes on what stands
is the stories the episodes of the show
itself
the marketing push and the anticipation
around a new announcement
while that will linger in your memory as
far as doctor who
as a cultural and artistic artifact is
concerned it doesn't really matter
and so it strikes me as an odd reason to
hold back
from trying this out that said
there may be some ways to kind of
have your cake and eat it too i've seen
it floated more than a few places the
idea of giving joe martin
some sort of spin-off or side
series now this actually isn't a
completely new suggestion
the same idea got floated in fan
communities after we finally got to see
paul mcgann on screen again in night of
the doctor
obviously it didn't happen then and if
i'm being completely honest i don't
actually think that's a viable option
that's not to say it's not viable
artistically i mean in terms of
it actually happening with the bbc i
just don't
see that being something that they'll do
after the end of class there really
seems to be no appetite
at the bbc for spin-offs of doctor who
at
all so i just don't think it's realistic
but
you know what that shouldn't kill us
talking about the hypothetical
so let's set the viability of whether or
not it would actually happen
aside and talk about what kind of shape
something like that
might take if it were to happen
now obviously with people floating the
idea of something like a spin-off
the natural inclination would be to do
something like torchwood
or class or the sarah jane adventures
and have it running
basically concurrently i mean maybe not
airing
literally in the same chunk of time but
like within the same year
you know having this stuff go on at the
same time maybe even having it here at
the same time i don't know
but that's one possibility but that's
one that i actually don't think is a
good idea and i said the same thing when
i saw people
float the idea of paul mcgann getting
a concurrent side series what that does
is inherently
split the fandom so
if you have joe martin and and like
narratively this would be
the way they would have to do it if she
is well not necessarily but
this might be the way they would have to
do it if she is established as not being
the 14th doctor but some sort of earlier
incarnation
and so theoretically the way that would
look is joe martin gets
a a side series showing her adventures
while the whoever the 14th doctor ends
up being moves forward in the main
show but that
like i said is going to inherently
divide the fandom as now we have
i mean it's all it's always an argument
who's the best doctor but
now it's going to get amplified to god
knows what
levels by having it be which is the best
doctor
right now and not that's an argument
that's going to be further fueled by the
fact that one of them
is in a side series and the other is the
main one
like that's just that is just built to
cause
fan wars and i'm not necessarily saying
that creators or even the business ends
should be super concerned about
whether or not something's going to take
off fans in terms of getting them
arguing with each other
worrying too much about that is how you
get literally nothing done
but at the same time that really would
be
something that would divide fans
loyalties in a way that i think would be
detrimental
to support for doctor who as a whole and
also just for the franchise from an
artistic standpoint it inherently
puts them as battling against each other
and that's not going to be good for
either one if they do that
alternately you could have it be
something a little bit more
like a one-off or even
an alternating series with the main one
so you could have it as say instead of
having them within the same year
one year of whoever the 14th doctor ends
up being one year joe martin
that still has the potential to have the
same
overall impact of dividing the fan pace
but at least spreading them out so
they're not
layering on top of each other would
remove at least
some of that or at least dampen it a
little bit but i still think that would
happen to a certain degree
and if you were to offer something like
a
mini series or a special even like
give her the holiday special and then
intro like whatever let's say
theoretically
jody whitaker regenerates at the end of
series 13.
give joe martin the holiday special as
anticipation to
um the you know whatever is going to
happen next
maybe even hint at whoever became the
14th doctor after that in that story
however you want to do it
and then after that we get series 14
with 14th doctor
that's not a terrible idea on
certain levels because it would allow
for her to have something that is more
self-contained and is not is not built
in such a way that inherently puts it at
odds with the main show quite as much
depending on
how you went about marketing and like
making it clear that we're doing this as
a one-off like as
like a six-episode special series or
something like that
but there is a really big problem with
doing that that has to do
with joe martin's standing
as the doctor because it inherently
makes her
a lesser doctor because no matter what
you
think about say for instance
the war doctor he's not going to be at
the top of anybody's list
of best doctors because he was there so
briefly
he's basically there are two specials
and then a bunch of side material
it was honest it's honestly the same way
with mcgahn to a certain extent
unless you are the kind of fan who digs
into the novels the audio dramas and
things like that
you just are never going to have a
proper appreciation for that character
now that in and of itself isn't the end
of the world except we've got the added
layer
where if they did if they went that way
if they just gave her a special
well that would mean that the first
black doctor ever wasn't
treated the same as all the previous
doctors in the main series
she was never even given the chance to
truly be the doctor
even megan while he was
kind of had no option to play the part
other than an audio for a very very very
long time
there was still the potential had the tv
movie been more successful for him to
continue in the role
that wasn't ever going to be the case
with the war doctor but john hurt
between
age and also you know how high profile
he was it was never designed to be
anything more than that
and also john hurt you know he's he's
just kind of an older weary doctor okay
the first black doctor matters
and to treat that character
the first time they've been black as
something that is lesser
to treat that character as someone who
is worthy of a spin-off
a special or worst case scenario
no appearances outside whatever
storyline is going on with the timeless
child arc that chibnall's doing
that that inherently frames
the black doctor the first black doctor
as being lesser
and that for me is too big a factor
especially when you combine with the
fact that like she was really good
that's too big a factor to
have anybody other than her be the 14th
doctor
in my mind because that's
frankly insulting and it's
not really okay and
in case anyone's gonna suggest this as a
way to counter mandate
no it wouldn't really fix it
if you cast someone else to be the 14th
doctor
who was also a black actor because you
still treated the first one
like she wasn't worthy
of the kind of treatment and stories and
even attempts at longevity
that every other main numbered doctor
has been afforded
or at least was planned and hoped to
have had
and that's messed up any way you slice
it
that's messed up and if you're gonna say
to me well you're just dragging
politics into this well yeah
yeah i am because i feel the same way
if instead of being the first black
doctor if joe martin was the first
explicitly
queer doctor either explicitly
non-binary
um bisexual pansexual lesbian
and yes i know they've hinted at that
with some of the other doctors but it's
never been explicit up to this point
so if it was that i know i'd be offended
as heck
that it would feel like you know oh here
look
we gave you the queer doctrine like
there you're satisfied now we're done
we're not going to do anything with that
again i would
be really mad and it's
not any different if it's a black doctor
so yeah yeah i'm bringing politics and
i'm bringing representation
into this conversation because it's
here not talking about it doesn't make
it suddenly vanish or go away
and if you feel that that is not a good
reason
to keep her on and have her be the 14th
doctor well
then i would say the most fair argument
that could be made is
if that was never going to happen then
maybe
chibnall never should have done this in
the first place with her casting because
it comes across as tokenism
and stunt casting and i do not want that
for her
she deserves better she deserves the
shot
for more than that and i'm sorry
if you would feel deprived
of the excitement of guessing
and of finding out whether or not you
were writing a big presentation or
you know oh a name i've never even heard
of or ooh this big get or whatever
i'm sorry i understand being
disappointed by that but
there will be more in future you'll have
that again
we're never going to have the chance to
give the first
black doctor her due ever again
because doing it doing something like
this with a future black actor
there's certainly no reason to not do
that but you only get one shot
at the first time
and throwing it away
just is not only a waste
it's unfeeling
it's not right
and i will continue to cross my fingers
and hope that whatever happens in series
13
if joe martin appears at all whatever
narrative details we get about her
further
allows for her to be the 14th doctor and
honestly
i personally would be willing
to allow for the idea that actually she
was a previous incarnation of the doctor
but she's now also going to be the 14th
doctor
the doctor has borrowed faces before
there isn't a reason the doctor can
borrow their own
and while generally speaking that is an
idea that scares me because it's just
going to lead to a campaign of people
going bring back david tennant
which look he had a shot he was great
he was wonderful but i don't want the
show to start looking back like that
this would strictly be a narrative
contrivance
because joe martin wasn't really the
doctor before
so from a narrative standpoint it might
establish okay the doctor can take the
faces
that they've had previously but from an
actual viewer perspective it wouldn't
really be that
so i'll allow it whereas the idea of
bringing back any of the earlier actors
to
be the new regeneration of the doctor
but also the old one i just kind of
turn my nose up at and go no no that's
that's how you get
franchises that just are
circle jerking around their old glory
days instead of trying to be something
new
and whatever you think about chibn's era
love it
loathe it it's not being the same thing
and whether you think that's bad or not
in terms of the specific things he's
been doing it is
healthy for the state of a franchise
that could
theoretically go on forever
there is no reason that doctor who ever
needs to end or ever needs to be
rebooted which i've talked about before
so with that in mind the worst thing
that a franchise like this could do
is start to circle back on itself and
focus more on what it used to be instead
of what it could be in the future
so there you have it
i think i know i said i was going to
entertain arguments for and against
you may have realized by now i think joe
martin should be the 14th doctor
i actually feel that very very very
strongly
and i'm doing my best to
give credence an understanding to the
arguments
against it but i
even if i can understand some of them i
cannot agree with them enough
to think that it isn't what should
happen i
feel this very strongly i think joe
martin should be the 14th doctor
will that happen i don't know i honestly
don't have a ton of faith that it will
but it should it should be
what happens what are your thoughts on
this
whatever they are keep them polite even
if you disagree with me
drop them on down in the comments and
let's talk about it i have a patreon and
that is how i pay my bills
there are rewards for every tier you can
get
access to videos early you can get your
name and the credits you can get access
to a patreon exclusive discord a lovely
very friendly place i'm very
proud to be able to have but
if you're not up for that there's also
youtube memberships if you want to check
out the rewards over there
but if you can't do that either
that's all right i'm not going to tell
you what to do
as strong as my feelings on various
things might be
because at the end of the day you are
the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you um
[Music]